bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors à la
demande du président de la république le
gouvernement tient manifestement montré
qu il se saisit du thème de l'insécurité
oui ce thème qui a été là tout l'été
avec ces faits divers tragiques de
personnes qui ont perdu la vie ces
scènes d'ultra violence qui inquiète les
français l'insécurité c'est un thème
aussi qui monte quand et bien les
français
les citoyens ont peur de l'avenir la
première fois qu'on parle de cette
violence de cette insécurité du
sentiment d'insécurité c'est en 77
peu après le choc pétrolier on commence
les pouvoirs publics commencent à
regarder comment faire alors le
gouvernement a voulu montrer qu'il était
concentré sur ce sujet c'est le sujet de
gérald darmanin depuis plusieurs jours
beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé on attend de
voir ce qu'il va être d'aider des faits
il ya d'une présentation du plan comme
comme vous le disiez l'idée c'est le
continuum sécuritaire c'est donc police
justice comment tout cela peut
fonctionner avec des budgets
supplémentaires 1 milliard pour la
sécurité la rénovation des commissariats
de nouvelles voitures des recrutements
10000 forces de l'ordre et voir comment
est bien faire que police et justice
travaillent ensemble pour que la peine
soit appliquée que les peines soient
proportionnelles et que finalement
l'insécurité le problème de l'insécurité
c'est le sentiment d'insécurité pour
beaucoup de français c'est une réalité
pour beaucoup de victimes c'est une
tragique réalité et pour d'autres ce
sont des chiffres faisant les chiffres
ne bougent pas donc la solution d'un
gérald darmanin ces deux chiffres est à
nouveau et de dire on va revoir la façon
dont on calcule dont on compte le
travail des forces de l'ordre et la
réalité de l'insécurité
du coup il ya eu une levée de boucliers
de la part des syndicats qui disent que
la politique du chiffre
ils la connaissent ils l'ont fait sous
nicolas sarkozy c'est de la pression de
la part du management et c'est pas
forcément de une réalité de terrain qui
change à propos de sécurité emmanuel
macron qui revient aujourd'hui justement
sur ces fameuses division dans son
propre camp auquel
que vous faisiez allusion avec une
pirouette si j'ose dire oui alors il
faisait allusion hilaire le chef de
l'état lors de son déplacement au fameux
kama sutra de l'ensauvagement qui
seraient le fait des médias qui
parlerait de l'ensauvagement davantage
que des réalités lui veut régler les
problèmes le vrai problème c'est pas le
kama sutra de l'ensauvagement c'est le
kama sutra du en même temps comment
elle-même acron qu'on veut faire pour
faire travailler ensemble gérald
darmanin à l'intérieur et eric dupond
moretti à la justice on voit bien ces
deux là se sont mis en scène ces
derniers jours se renvoyant la balle
l'un étant pour lens va jouer donc
c'était une réalité l'autre disons que
ça recouvre est totalement quelque chose
de faux derrière ces deux personnalités
publiques très visible un politique qui
souhaitent faire carrière est allé
beaucoup plus loin gérald darmanin et
dans un poste clé le ministère de
l'intérieur donc il entend bien prendre
ses marques comme nicolas sarkozy
l'avait fait comme manuel valls l'avait
fait avant lui et pour dupont moretti
c'est tout à fait autre chose il donne
des gages sur sa gauche en disant vous
inquiétez pas je suis de gauche donc ce
kama sutra du en même temps il a ses
limites je crois qu'il ya des positions
qu'on ne peut pas tenir et c'était le
cas aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron été obligé de rappeler à
l'ordre ses deux ministres en disant
qu'il ne devait pas mettre en scène la
dissension du gouvernement mais au
contraire mettre en oeuvre la politique
gouvernementale donc peut-être qu'après
ça on les entendra moins sur la justice
on attend ce sera dans les jours qui
viennent qu'on saura quels vont être les
mesures prises et le budget de la
justice
là encore c'est un grand flou encore un
séminaire pour beaucoup parlé et
finalement peu annoncé il ya eu
également la question du séparatisme
au menu également de ceux de ce
séminaire avec évidemment toujours le rn
en ligne de mire oui et ça c'est
extrêmement critiquée par les députés de
la majorité en marche en disant que
s'est donné beaucoup trop d'importance
aux thématiques du rassemblement
national c'est faire le jeu du
rassemblement national sans être sûr de
gagner cette fois sur le séparatisme les
portes est depuis longtemps un par
gérald darmanin bien avant qu'il soit à
ce poste du ministère de la culture il
avait déjà une position iconoclaste au
sein des républicains il a été casté par
areva kron pour ça pour justement faire
avancer cette loi sur le séparatisme on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui celui qui a la
maquille mur
murr alors avec des bennes al-bakr on
s'est davantage gérald darmanin qui fait
avancer tous ces thèmes de manière assez
rapide ans est rentré plus tôt que les
autres ministres qui sont en retrait et
un mot aujourd'hui je pense que certes
l'insécurité est un des thèmes qui
préoccupent les français mais ce qui les
préoccupe davantage comme je le disais
en introduction
c'est l'avenir et c'est l'emploi et de
l'emploi on attend encore une fois de
voir quelles vont être les réalités des
mesures et que peut faire ce
gouvernement sachant que le conseil de
sécurité et de défense se réunit
vendredi et qu'au risque d'avoir des
mesures encore difficile délicate pour
l'économie merci alexis polaire d'avoir
été avec no 1 mondial sur rt france